one question an amazing lineup of ceos
founders and experts this is marketing
for the now
[Music]
thank you so much that made me feel
[Music]
gary we are back
i'm so happy to be back everybody's back
in the office today this is it's uh it
feels it feels good
i didn't realize how much i missed it
i agree it's been really fun all right
so today we're going to focus on b2b and
we're going to kick it off with the
queen bee of b2b
tai heath who runs the b2b institute at
linkedin she ran a fabulous seminar at
cannes
and a quick fun fact about ty that i did
not know she was a two-time olympic
trials qualifier in the 800 meters
and that's i was just telling her i
think that's the hardest race you got to
go a long time and really fast which is
i think that it says a lot about our
ties so can't wait to
hear what you got to lay down tai
thank you big facts thanks for having me
the 800 meter is a full sprint folks
it's a full start
that's real stuff guys that's real stuff
how are you
oh you know i'm doing well it's good to
be here i love this we're focusing on
b2b today
i'm passionate about it so thanks for
having me of course let's talk about
that b2b is obviously actually before i
do that big shout out to adam meeks
mohamed sultan
jim michael on linkedin jennifer c on
facebook we got a bunch of people in
here
davey paul on facebook um
we talk a lot about b2c the world does
because we know about starbucks and nike
that we live through it the b2b
landscape is you know it's funny i'm
also very passionate i and i'm very
passionate about where you happen to be
now so this will be easy for me i
continue to be frustrated with b2b
marketing around the world we have a lot
of b2b inquiries a lot of b2b clients
and you know they're just overly
comfortable on running a print ad in
their industry magazine overly
comfortable
spending ungodly amounts of money on
trade shows that they've been going to
for 20 years they're not acquiring any
new companies customers excuse me they
know
they all those people at those trade
shows already know who those people are
and yet they continue to under invest in
modern marketing whether that is making
original programming on podcasts or
shows
and the place that i you know
you know for everybody's watching
uh
i've been saying this loud and proud for
five years so i'm not trying to make tai
feel nice though it's a nice byproduct i
am blown away how people have not
figured out that media and creative on
linkedin the way they think about
instagram facebook and tick tock and
snap and others
is the greatest opportunity for b2b
companies in the world and so i when we
when i knew we were doing this
i said to the team i'm like just make
sure linkedin's there because
that's you know there's so many fortune
5000 b2b cmos watching right now but
looking at the comments there's a ton of
service providers one shop lawyers
accountants kind of that smb b2b
audience that is heavy in here and i
want financial advisors and i want them
to understand the opportunity in the
space yeah linkedin is major for b2b
it is a platform where you can reach
customers employees leaders shareholders
it's it's the platform for b2b honestly
uh so i'm really glad that you're doing
my job gary here
telling the audience about it and in
regard to what you said about the
opportunity for b2b i you know wherever
there's a challenge wherever there's a
gap
there's an opportunity so i'm really
excited
about
b2b marketers really grasping
investment and creative the investment
in brand i think it's really exciting
and there are a lot of these major
brands that a lot of people don't know
about are b2b
right so i think there's a huge future i
think fast forward a year from now and
i'm thinking it's like a different
conversation that's my hope gary
what um what are the biggest
misconceptions and or
um
opportunities in
the way we set this up today which is
building brand and business in b2b
yeah i think the one of the foundational
things to remember is you know if you
think about what our job as a marketer
is
it is to build memories right we want
people to be
thinking about our brands we want to be
remembered more often than not the brand
that's remembered as the brand that's
bought so marketers are actually in the
memory business
and what b2b marketers can start
thinking about a little bit more is how
do you link your brand to relevant
buying situations so in our b2b
institute research where think tank we
work with leading academics and
practitioners to investigate how
marketers can create value we
work with this uh wonderful organization
called erenberg bass institute and they
have this concept called category entry
points and these are
when buyers enter the market
and so we want when buyers enter the
market that our brands are the ones that
come to mind
and if your customers don't know your
brand when they enter the market then
it's already too late so
one i think going back to what you said
about misconceptions it's what business
are we in memory so that means
investment in creativity
uh and i think the other big one is you
know the the balance of brand to demand
and how we're investing in that it the
b2b institute we have this
uh franchise called b2b trends for the
contrarian marketer and a key trend to
take a look at folks is one called the
95 5
rule 95
95 5 rule and you know
taking it back to like the funnel the
marketing funnel which is one of the
most recognized mental models for
marketing of all time you know the
misconception is that you know there's
the awareness stage the consideration
stage we put that to the side what we
believe
is that buyers are either in market or
out market
for your business and so the funnel the
problem with the funnel is it leads
marketers to believe
that you're responsible for placing
can i can i ask you something on that
before i lose you here because i know
these go so fast for the there's a lot
of normals in here maybe weren't
classically trained let me ask you a
question on that
where do you think relevance falls in
right
you know i think the biggest issue in
marketing is people make one video tv
and it's completely vanilla because
they're trying to reach everybody and
for everyone me and you and for
seth leroy and flavio a and karen gp and
tim g right now
it's hard for that advertising to mean
something to us because it has no teeth
it has no relevance it doesn't speak to
me it doesn't say hey did you grow up an
immigrant selling lemonade then i'm like
whoa
i want to buy that car i want like you
know like it doesn't even stop us to
your point in market not
the the issue is for coffee
for for
sneakers they're always in market
potentially to your point
in b2b land especially
bigger company you go to fortune 500
land it's once every three years it's
once every year but but to me where i
the work the creative doesn't have
enough
relevance specific
truths to it thus rendering it
to a place where b2b companies are more
sales organizations not marketing
organizations
thoughts
right
well you know the key is you want to be
remembered in the first place that's the
first hurdle to get over so
you want to think about what we call
relevant buying situations and be known
so it's it's being remembered but it's
also being remembered in the context of
the situation
and there are there are levels to this
right so
you know do are people aware of your
existence do are they aware of your
existence in a particular situation you
mentioned coffee people love coffee
right are they thinking about what brand
of coffee are they thinking about when
they're walking to work
when they're at home on the weekend
with their family or friends so now you
it's not just about
relevance it's about being relevant in a
particular situation and the holy grail
is being thought of and linking your
brand to as many of those buying
situations as possible but the other
piece i think you're you're speaking to
here gary is this
um
idea of you know what kind of ads help
us get there so it's the creativity the
memory devices that help us be
remembered at the brand level
right so thinking about using characters
emotion
music all these things that help implant
the memory for people but that's not a
space where i think many b2b marketers
are playing right now we tend to overly
focus on
features uh we have another trend called
the product delusion
where people you know talk about here
are all the things that you know our
br our products can do
where if we're not remembered or known
in the first place it doesn't matter it
doesn't exactly so that's what i'm
that's the distinction that i want to
make about relevance for people who want
to start i think it's a revolutionary
concept to actually think about relevant
buying situations that coffee example
you brought up i think is a good or hey
or a linkedin post with a video that is
actually interesting that says hey are
you a cio and struggling with this exact
thing we're just everything's so vanilla
it's like every b2b campaign's the same
i'm actually looking at a b2b outdoor
right now and says
actually that's airpods i thought it was
there but like you know it's like every
b2b campaign's the same it's like tai
it's like we're empowering your future
we're gonna make it like it's come on
marketers
anyway ty we've run out of time thank
you so much continued success
thank you for having me i appreciate it
thanks tai
gary next we're going to welcome michael
roberts who is the cmo of metlife and
he's a member on its executive
leadership team
he leads brand and marketing globally
and if he has a very interesting fun
fact as well
michael is an opera singer we've got
quite the talent here today we really do
opera singers olympians i mean it's
how are you my friend
i'm doing well gary it's good to be here
it's great to have you here i mean
especially because you know i was at
metlife stadium a couple days ago uh so
i always have a lot of love for metlife
because of my new york jets talk about
talk about why naming like this is
actually very funny based on what we
were just talking about yeah no joke i'm
like feel warm towards you
because
you're the naming rights of my favorite
pastime and that's an affinity relevance
thing that i think
i'd like to continue on the path i'm
sure you were listening what's your take
on that michael like you know am i am i
right or am i over hyperbolizing or do
we need to get out of vanilla
yeah i i think i think we do need to get
out of you know i think relevance is an
important concept you know for for b2b
marketers to embrace
i also love what what ty said about the
the funnel this this funnel needs to be
set aside you know what i found is that
you know the most important thing is to
get consideration and consideration
happens at the moment of need and so if
you're not getting consideration at a
moment in need then you are irrelevant
um or if you're talking to people when
they don't have a need then you're also
irrelevant and so you know this is why
you know i think that from what i've
seen in the analytics that i've done is
that consideration has the highest
predictive value for sales in the b2b
space right that's what we
michael to educate some of the kids
coming up the game or some of the people
that haven't
been thinking about this
what is your guess and i know this is a
guess we'd all be guessing
but
br play this game out between b2b
marketing versus being sales
organizations
yeah because you know even in cpg land
where pepsi procter and gamble the sales
team's always got a little cynical view
of the marketers they think they're just
putting around wasting money
in b2b land it's even more profound
because
you know these are big contracts there's
a lot that goes into it
um
you know what's your gut tell you that
of let's say the b2b fortune 500 the top
500 b2b companies in the world
what's your personal like guess on like
how much dna they have in sales versus
how much they actually have in marketing
are they 80 20 sales organizations out
there are they 50 50 like what's your
take
yeah so i would i'd look at i'd add
another category to it gary especially
especially in the b2b world i'd i'd say
there are engineering focused firms as
well right and so yes so you get yes you
have this
sap in my in my building here that is a
german engineered dna business
right and and you could you could take
it out of just technology and call it
product right so you've got sales
product and marketing and and i think
you know depending on the industry
you're going to get overweight in one of
them and most of most companies are are
are either overweight in product or in
sales and marketing kind of follows
along follows product or follow sales or
or it tries to cut its own path and
and is is generally not successful and
so that's what i think has created you
know let's just do the same thing that
the sales people or the product people
are happy with over and over again you
know and and not create any not create
any noise and i think that's one of the
reason why you see this this vanilla um
but you know the opportunity michael
michael i apologize real quick
uh maroon i apologize real quick varun
ted party said in linkedin watching live
gary will never see my comment i just
wanted to prove to him that i would
continue my friend continue i love it i
love it gary but let's go this goes back
to relevance right right now in the meta
we're doing awareness
but taking the micro second to say hello
to amir lam or jacob rick or chris oh or
ryan miller like
things happen from that and i think
there's a huge opportunity within that
there is there is i think the the
opportunity though you know back to your
your question gary is is for you know
sales marketing product to create a go
to market ecosystem it's not about any
of them it's about the commercial
outcome and it's about how the team
works together on the commercial outcome
i think too too often the marketers are
trying to prove marketing works
right versus 100 and you know this as a
cmo of such a big company a lot of these
i mean i always tell people like real
life like real talk on this show
measuring brand is like measuring the
value of god or love
like it's it's it's just i i'm aware
that you have i'm sure your company and
every company i mean every client we
have has a mechanism whether it's an
internal mmm mma nielsen brand lift
studies inter-brand rankings and i sit
and watch all these trillions of dollars
wasted to justify and common sense not
having a seat at the table
yeah i mean that's that's the key is
like yes there's a whole bunch of these
measures which are important for
strategy or for optimization but those
aren't the measures of what marketing is
delivering from a value perspective
these are the commercial outcomes that
the business needs to see and marketing
needs to take you know take
accountability for their participation
in the in the ecosystem that creates
those commercial outcomes and that that
means that it's not about marketing it's
about the commercial outcomes and how
marketing can enable it with with things
that drive those commercial outcomes
more and more directly this is this is
why back to your point of relevance like
you know consideration being
being you know highly you know i would
say highly predictive based on the
predictive models i've seen is highly
predictive of sales because it means
that you're relevant it's just it's just
so obvious it's like it's and i always
try to break this down to normal
conversations for humans like
if you're if you're attracted to another
human being on first sight
there's a higher percentage chance that
you may have a relationship with that
person because you're considering i
would like to date that person like it's
just the way it works and it's it's
really it's really fascinating talk to
me about something that i'm really
passionate about in building brand
do you believe the biggest brands in the
world or even smallest do you feel like
they continue to underestimate the power
of
you know creative and content in social
because we've all been trained in
television and outdoor
because it's so hard to
watch people speak about social networks
as like demise to democracy
right and and the biggest challenge in
parenting because everyone's consuming
it but then when we check into metlife
or chase or pepsi we forget that those
channels are actually dominating our
society what do you think is and from
your own personal view i meant like
maybe do you feel like we're starting to
rev up on the way i started this show
which is like making a ton of content
for linkedin every day and having it
targeted and make the content relevant
to that target might be a better
use of our money do you feel like that's
starting to finally be accepted or be
thought about or at least
debated a little bit i i think we're
really really early i mean i think it's
really really early i think we we should
be doing it um you know you know these
these platforms are
dominating attention um yeah you know
and so and they're dummy in attention
with algorithms that enable people to
find what's relevant to them so back to
this relevance comment and so where's
the best way to find relevance it's in
the place where you continue to find it
which is going to be some of these some
of these social media platforms
and you know i think i think it's it's
incumbent on all of us to actually start
to really understand the
you know we we all talk about just as
you said the social impact of of these
platforms but there's a business impact
to these platforms which i think is has
been muted in some way and i'm agreeing
to figure out a way to have that
conversation you know even while we're
still having the social
the social impact conversation uh for
these platforms
michael well well said i'm wishing you
well thank you
all right take care gary
thank you michael
so gary we're bringing jim stengel back
up for another conversation
jim stengel is the president and ceo of
the jim stangle company formerly the
global cmo of procter and gamble but
he's also the host of the cmo podcast a
senior fellow at northwestern kellogg a
speaker with the washington speakers
bureau and an advisor to many companies
thanks for joining us we know it's a
busy day jim we really appreciate it
andrea so good to see you love the
earrings
thank you
hi gary
hey
yeah i know a lot of people got caught
simon louden somebody you probably know
i got caught in dallas yesterday texted
me missed a meeting so i know there was
a lot going there uh for everybody who's
watching jim is this is just i'm gonna
give him roses because i think we need
to be giving each other more roses while
we're alive these in society is truly
one of the iconic cmos of all time in
advertising he uh was a cmo at procter
gamble which is obviously one of the
biggest consumer goods companies but
why i think he's remarkable is behind
the scenes he's also one of the great
human beings of all time just a
gentleman a kind soul
um
courteous like every i promise you
everything you want your son and
daughter to grow up to be as a human
being that is jim stengel and i just
wanted to say that
oh gary thank you thank you
i mean it as we've gotten to know each
other more and more and more every time
i'm left with more admiration uh and
you're just a wonderful person the way
you make you know i'm very proud of the
way i make people feel both through
scaled content but more importantly the
people that are close to me that
actually know every truth i find that
every person i meet that knows you the
best loves you the most and the people
that barely know you love you and that
is
that is the great indication of a man
and so i wanted you to know that
gary i love working with you your team
the podcast has been a great joy in my
life so thank you for that you made me
do it a few years ago
i'm so so happy you were relaxed so
let's let's let's go for a few minutes
on this you've been listening i i assume
unless you were busy before you jumped
on
what do we need to do to get these b2b
companies to get more contemporary like
ma like stop mailing in a tv campaign
stop mailing in an outdoor campaign stop
mailing in a mail or print campaign stop
mailing in spending eight million
dollars on a trade show but doing
nothing in the new contemporary lanes
what are you seeing out there jim
gary
i was uh i was at cannes this year can
lions a big marketing festival you know
it was back and forth as you know we
were there together and we held for the
first time ever a b to b summit and
linkedin sponsored it so we had all the
players there adobe salesforce intuit a
ge microsoft mckinsey tata you name it
and the issue gary is actually very
simple and there this was the first year
can where there was a b2b creative lion
so they were giving awards for b2b
marketing
and the top one went to sherwood
williams for a wonderful idea about
color
but
the issue is the ambition
the standards the expectations
so why
why isn't b2b as creative and
contemporary and relevant as the best
consumer brands
what is the reason there is not a good
one
can we throw one can
one fun one i'm empathetic to the
following statement
that for a lot of people
consumer brands
are more shiny right if you're a very
creative person
the idea of being the cmo for starbucks
or paluton or equinox or
reebok
because you know so many more people
will see it
just might be more compelling than doing
it for ibm and h and all these great
companies but you know that it's going
to be insular you're not going to be
doing
the sizzle stuff per se
and that makes some of the talent skew
that way that might have more fire on
the flip side to your point
so many of the cmos that andrea uh has
become close with you know
uh play in b2b and have become some of
my most favorite people and i find them
equally as creative i almost think
subconsciously
they don't think they can go there
and i think that's a
that's a boogeyman that's not true
that's the paradigm we were breaking at
this at this session but you know ryan
rozlanski the ceo at linkedin made an
amazing presentation
at cannes this year and he came to visit
the the forum
he basically said you know most of the
economic value in this world to be
created in the next few decades is
b2b so why the hell
aren't creative people flocking to the
b2b brand because the issue is consumer
brands have begun very become very good
at telling a story
right when i when you think about apple
you think about disney you think about
tide you know the story because they
have been consistent they've been
creative
b2b brands
many of them do not tell a story there's
not a clear promise there's lots of
features and functions but not a promise
so ryan's call to the industry is the
best creative talent needs to come into
b2b and the clients need to set really
high expectations
to tell a clear story a compelling story
and treat their customers like human
beings
and not some sort of
platform robot do you think do you think
that do you think the combo we've been
having about
these companies ultimately are just two
sales
dna oriented also i mean all these poor
cmos you've been in this game way longer
and have more relationships but i have a
ton now in b2b cmos and from week three
they start already getting internal
feedback where the sales team is
[ __ ] on marketing
and they're they they're on their back
foot before they've started i think the
ceos
of the b2b companies in the world need
to really step up and understand this
truth and put their cmos in a position
to succeed
yeah absolutely gary and i know the
conversation we're having with michael
just before we need to get we need more
innovation and attribution
right yeah we cannot measure as as
specifically as we need to brand
marketing and the impact on performance
we're all about performance marketing
because we can measure it brand
marketing is suffering the spending is
moving to performance because we can't
measure it we need innovation there and
i've invested in the software platform
to do that
brand marketing drives results we need
to show that we need more innovation
i promise you
i promise you that i did not buy this
because somebody cookied me
on a website and they retargeted me
that's right right and not only this if
for people that know this it's all brand
there is nothing else somebody just said
gary why do you keep grabbing the toys
off your shelf because i'm trying to
build the v friends ip and even the
impression of major moth right now
becomes a brand story i'm not cooking
gwen wilcox or fiona sparks and
retargeting them a pre-roll to buy a v
friend i'm building story
yeah absolutely i was just i just
interviewed here in dallas uh catherine
reeves is the cmo of illumina which is a
b2b genomics company b2b they serve a
lot of healthcare platforms laboratories
you know she said
you know let's not treat our customers
like a robot you know let's go to where
they are let's tell our story let's
bring them into our fold let's let's
have them join a coalition where we're
trying to make people's lives better
that's the way to think about b2b and
they're doing phenomenally well
i love that jim
i'll just give you the floor for last
two minutes i have anything that we
didn't touch on in the first two guests
or now together that might be something
worth for the smb
b2b people here as a tactical thing or
maybe just a genre even for fortune 50
you can go the other direction that we
maybe didn't touch on
i just think the same skills we think
about in consumer brands empathy
listening creativity
dial up the empty you know when we had
this forum it can it was all about how
can we be more empathetic how can we
listen more how can we treat our
customers like human beings how can we
make a difference in their lives so
again gary these are these are
principles and marketing forever but we
don't exercise them considerably
jim do you believe that creative is too
expensive thus rendering brands not
having enough at bats to win on
relevance
i don't think that's an excuse
do you think that's a reality right
because i think the thing i'm spending a
lot of time on trying to get people to
be able to when you talk about empathy
to be empathetic to millions of people
requires relevance to millions of people
yeah that's right that's right to do
relevance you need to do creative that
actually speaks to the empathy i have
absolutely i'll give you an example i
have equal empathy for the following two
people someone that is born into a
family with so little little that they
grow up the way i did immigrating
there's a lot of ch
i equally have empathy for someone who's
born into an extremely wealthy family
thus rendering anything they accomplish
null and void because everyone will tell
you you were born on third base those
are two very different human stories and
if i'm a brand b to b or b to c that's
trying to capture that conversation with
that individual i need two very
different stories
the distribution model of television
makes so much sense it was what was our
profound mechanism but i believe that
the creative ad industry is still built
as if that's the reality when
all these platforms now give us the
actual opportunity to win on relevance
but nobody's producing a hundred pieces
of creative that are meaningful and
quality against this opportunity per
month let alone per
decade because creative and adland
in the model that was built for
television properly is too expensive to
take advantage of thoughts
no i do think that's a paradigm but i
think what has to happen is
the creative the best creative companies
in the world and you're ahead of one of
them need to be having discussions with
these b2b companies the ones that are
going to create the most value in the
world over the next 20 or 30 years by
the way the next top 10 ipos are all b2b
yep you know we need to be having a
discussion they need creativity
in their companies many of them are
lacking that so if if i'm gary and a big
big b2b company that is going to get 10
times the size comes to you and says
here are our challenges
you have a lot of problem solvers in
your company let's come together let's
find a way to share the value
and let's do great work
that conversation
that was our team love you my friend
okay gary love youtube see ya thank you
jim and thank you gary
we're gonna welcome
miss kaelin mcnamara it's about time
kalyn hello i made it
i'm so excited to have you on the show
i'm excited
kailyn is the svp of new business in
addition to running vayner's consulting
practice which is growing growing
growing and we have a number of
different b2b offerings in fact um but
we're here to talk with jesse today very
excited to have jesse purewall join us
who is the global head of brand at
qualtrics
jesse um is also the host of
breakthrough builders podcast a qualtric
sponsored show that celebrates people
whose passions have impacted the world
i'm so excited to hear this story
hi jessie good to see you kailyn great
to be with you happy wednesday happy
middle of the week you too i'm really
excited for this i really appreciate you
taking the time why don't we start just
give everyone a little bit of context on
your background and what you're up to at
qualtrics
yeah so my background is i i am a career
brand builder i started off
um over a dozen years at profit which is
a growth strategy consultancy focused on
brand i focus on marketing and one of my
clients you know i focused a lot on b2b
and i will i will say you know sexy is
in the eye of the beholder i find uh
because man once you get me into the
software company or platform as a
service or iot or ai like that's that's
my magic that's my mojo um one of my
clients over the course of that journey
was was qualtrics and when i got a
chance to join and be part of the
marketing team and lead up brand i just
i just jumped on it and um man it's been
an incredible journey and we're
so happy to be kind of in the
glide path and and in the tailwind of so
many of these kinds of discussions that
have just been happening over the past
past few minutes we think hard about
relevance heart about empathy hard about
connecting with people where they are
and and as human beings so couldn't be
more excited i love it what i find so
interesting about your business is while
you're a b2b company you're experts in
the consumer experience right and so i'm
curious one maybe give a little bit more
context on qualtrics as a brand for
those who might not be as familiar and
how do you see sort of that real
understanding of consumer and customer
experience impact uh sort of your
marketing and brand strategy and
obviously i'm sure in many ways it gives
you a leg up and i can also imagine the
stakes are high in terms of you know the
experience that you look to deliver to
your customers as a brand
yeah well look you're it's a flattering
statement so thank you for saying you
know that that we do kind of grok the
consumer side we're we're learning right
we're learning just like everybody else
in in b2b uh you know qualtrics is a
company that got its start 20 years ago
i mean many of you probably know
qualtrics because you filled out a
survey on delta airlines or hilton
hotels or some place about how was your
experience and how was your service and
the company for many years was all about
this kind of structured solicited data
ingest to get data to go improve
employee and customer experiences now
improving and designing customer
experiences is what we're still all
about we created a category called
experience management to do just that
but the really exciting thing about our
technology and the evolution of our
innovation agenda is that it's more
pointed at unstructured data and
unsolicited data so you know the yelps
of the world the review sites
tripadvisors social being able to have a
clear picture of like what does an
employee think not just in terms of
their quarterly pulse but things that
are saying on glassdoor blind or others
and then what customers think not just
about filling out surveys you know when
they get them in their email but what
are they saying or review sites
everywhere so that people who are
marketers people who are cx
practitioners people who are in the
office of the chro can say like oh this
is where we're doing well this is where
we have to go close those experience
gaps that's what our software allows and
you that's
empathy at scale like when you are
getting opinions and feeling a sentiment
that's empathy at scale and so it's it's
just a beautiful brand to get to steward
in the sense that
it's technology it's innovation it's
kind of platform
but but it's also really about improving
the human experience and so we have an
opportunity and we have an obligation
to create content that is a great
experience in and of itself because of
the business we're in because of the
category that we're in i love it it's a
great segue to my next one which is i
think what we saw on our end across the
b2b industry in particular was a massive
shift as sort of you know travel was
halted trade shows halted all the
typical kind of sales and marketing
activity completely you know brought to
a stop a lot of brands did use it as a
time to really rethink in this modern
world how should we invest in content
what should that look like and how do we
use this as sort of a moment of
reflection to maybe think differently
about building brand and so i would love
for you to talk a little bit about xm
plus because i think it's a great
example of i think what we at vayner are
really sort of preaching which is what
gary even just was riffing on earlier in
terms of trying to provide actual value
and create connection first um but all
at the same time you know understanding
that at the end of the day it's about
driving business i would love for you to
talk a bit more about the pivot of your
content strategy and that platform
specifically yeah you bet and um
you know you nailed it right because it
is all about connecting and and i want
to bring it back to some of the stuff
that i talked about and that gary talked
about with jim you know being human
empathy and creativity and and relevance
and tai talked about
uh you know the 95 5 rule you know some
constituted as the 90 10 rule but
whatever you think of those integers
look in b2b at any given moment
90 of the folks who are in our total
addressable market our tam our category
are not actively in a purchase cycle and
so that means that 90 of our potential
customers in any given time are not
indicating intent they're not going to
respond to a demand gen campaign they're
not going to download that ebook they're
not going to go look for that white
paper they're going to scroll past
instead of having their thumb stopped
and so what we have to do is meet people
and be pervasively and persistently
relevant in the stories that we tell the
content that we offer
and
be courageous about un-gating it and
allowing them to access it without
having to give the exchange of the email
address people talk about free
nothing's free once you sign your email
address out we firmly believe we've got
to create content that resonates deeply
and it's pervasively available and
relevant at the same time
as you said sort of you know coming out
of the pandemic and looking at what's
next
we looked at what the disney pluses of
the world were doing what the hbo maxes
of the world are doing it's like holy
smokes like
in a world of hybrid work
people aren't going to tolerate a bad
content experience in their work lives
and have a delightful one in their home
lives as as consumers as family members
like
who's going to step in and fill the
vacuum
of creating b2b content at scale that's
both relevant
and also deeply inspiring and as a
company that's all about improving the
human experience we're like we want to
be that company
and so we said look we are going to go
out there with the xm plus platform
called xm plus xm for experience
management
stories about how to run your business
as an experience stories about how
brands win on experience stories about
how employers are winning by crafting
engagement strategies that are employee
first not not company first
and just the the creativity and and the
storytelling and the relevance to a
broad audience that we're building there
we feel really confident based on the
early signal we're seeing as well as our
our intuitions and where we know this
needs to go this is a great way to
invite people to understand more about
what we're doing with qualtrics spot on
and for anyone who gets a chance to
check out the content i think what's
amazing is it doesn't take the form of
branded content or ads it's
documentaries it's storytelling that you
would consume you know on a saturday
night you know on netflix in terms of
format and so uh preaching to the choir
there i think last question because we
got one minute left is andrea mentioned
in your intro sort of the you're the
host of the break uh um um the
breakthrough builders podcast um for
anyone who hasn't heard it check it out
amazing guests great content where do
you know we get a lot of clients that
are interested in podcasting and trying
to fit where does that fit into their
sort of content strategy how do you see
the role of the podcast in terms of
fueling the brand story and then
obviously for you as a personal brand
what have you sort of learned or seen
through that experience yeah
you know
folks
don't want to hear
qualtrics talking about qualtrics folks
want to hear
customers people in our community
leaders who have created great
experiences and put them in the world
talk about those experiences and and
what we do in the podcast is we we
basically shine a light on people that
we believe have created great
experiences and put them in the world
and have them talk about their personal
journeys how do they get to where they
are in their career what choices did
they make what tensions did they have to
resolve and as professionals how do they
think about running their businesses as
experiences you know i think about you
know people that we've had on the show
um
are catherine chin who runs the cx
program at twilio robert chatwani who's
the chief marketing officer at
atlassian um we've had you know even dan
pink the author of seven different books
talk about how he
writes you know for an experience that
his his readers will have you know we've
had you know david meltzer right in in
the family um you know reflect on his
journey uh just so many people matt
kayla she runs draftkings rebecca
minkoff you know these people who put
these iconic products and brands and
experiences into the world and say like
how did you do it what was your fuel
and when people listen to that and
understand like oh
these are how people that are respected
leaders down the world build experiences
they just begin to associate qualtrics
as a brand more and more
with experience and it's not the hard
sell here's our product some people
aren't even necessarily cultural
customers and we don't care we just want
to celebrate great experiences because
that's what we're all about yep awesome
great and again things people actually
want to consume which i think has been
the punchline of the chat awesome well
jesse thank you so much for the time
yeah you bet thanks for having me team
that was great thanks jesse
all right kalyn we've got another one a
great one coming up we're gonna bring on
siddharth taparia who is the global
chief marketing officer at jll
we've known siddharth for a little while
right
back when your long tenure at sap you
came from tech roots and have now
transferred to yet another industry
it's fascinating your background your
accomplished author and advisor on data
privacy cloud computing and value driven
marketing and interestingly i love that
you grew up in india where you studied
engineering and got a degree in
information technology
welcome siddharth
andrea it's great to see you hi there
hi kellen hello appreciate this love
your background excited to sort of chat
a little bit why don't we start um and
just give everyone a little bit of
context on you
as well as about jl the brand
yeah i mean i joined jl last year as the
global chief marketing officer and gll
really didn't have a global cmo role
before i joined
which was very exciting because uh jll
is a fortune 200 company with uh 19.5
billion in revenue we do business in in
80 countries we have over 100 000
employees so very large global footprint
uh and we're all about uh real estate
and real estate services so that's uh
what we do for our clients and our
clients belong to all industries i know
we've been talking about b2b b2c
um
we work with our clients on every aspect
of their real estate footprint and what
really excited me was
the opportunity to come and be part of
something
really that was at the beginning at the
very beginning stages of the brand being
built out the company sort of starting
to find its footprint in the market uh
from a brand perspective
but also just build out the
the entire uh operating model of
marketing uh because the company really
didn't do marketing at scale uh in the
past it was very localized which
commercial real estate tends to be a
very local business but uh now it is an
opportunity to do things at scale and
really elevate the brand
love it i mean yeah i mean obviously
every industry was disrupted the past
two years in one way or another but
that's i think more than most right
complete um you know pivot right in
terms of how you think about not just
sort of the category but also consumer
behavior and sort of the future of
workplace would love as somebody who
lives down the jersey shore i am excited
sad that summer's over but i'm excited
to get back into the office and sort of
get back into the rhythm and i think
everybody has their own sort of journey
around that what are you seeing sort of
being on the front lines as we think
about sort of return to work return to
office as well as sort of the future of
sort of workplace environment
yeah i mean it's a it's a very
interesting time because you know more
and more companies are trying to come
out with mandates and and you know
sometimes employees are pushing back
petitioning uh their employer and saying
we don't want to be back in the office
people did rearrange their lives around
working from home you're you're working
from home i'm today working from home uh
certainly because
it's more convenient for for a variety
of different personal and professional
reasons
but we just uh we just did a survey uh
which is called the future of work
survey people can go read it online uh
just came out and and it's interestingly
72 percent of people uh of respondents
and this is a survey we did across 13
countries um basically said in the long
term the office will remain
critical uh to the organization's
ecosystem so they still believe the
office is critical but at the same time
and here's the contradiction 77 percent
of of our respondents also either agree
or strongly agree that offering remote
or hybrid working options is critical to
attracting and retaining uh talent and
so it's this this dichotomy that we're
seeing in the market which is people
want to uh be back in the office to be
able to meet other people to be able to
collaborate see their customers see
their uh colleagues but at the same time
they don't want to be back in the office
monday through friday uh and log in at
eight in the morning and go back home at
five in the evening
absolutely and i think as a lot of the
themes we've had today is it's
understanding the context and those
nuances we talked about it sort of in
the media landscape just how forever
fragmented attention is going to be i
think similarly in your category the
understanding of those nuances is
important obviously in sort of your sort
of you know sales and marketing strategy
but also just the understanding of
culture and how it's forever going to be
that sort of yes and right uh mindset uh
in the future um having uh celebrated a
career both b to b and b to c we
obviously as a company service b to b
and b to c and one trend we see is every
b2b company wanting to be more b2c in
dna and now b2c companies really getting
focused on sort of more of the sales
performance you know side of things what
is your perspective on sort of the
similarities between b2b and b2c and uh
and then obviously sort of the nuances
where you think there needs to be a more
distinct uh point of view for b2b
companies
yeah i i found a discussion that gary
was having with jim stengel very
interesting and and also i don't agree
with uh some parts of it because i i
think there are things that are very
universal so if you have a strong brand
it it applies no matter what if people
know you uh if they understand who you
are as a company what what you care
about what your values are they're going
to be attracted by you if i have two
companies that have that are exactly the
same one that i've never heard of and
one that i have seen before uh there's
just a good likelihood of me selecting
the one that i've seen before so at the
simplest level having a strong brand
matters and matters deeply i think where
the differences start to emerge is
um people don't realize this and people
who haven't worked in b2b oftentimes
don't realize this i've worked 15 years
at sap and i've been i met another b2b
company gll
sales cycles in b2b tend to be extremely
long uh this is not about seeing an ad
clicking by and buying something in the
next five minutes and you can do
attribution when you're talking about
sometimes six month year long 18-month
long sales cycles um the attribution to
marketing becomes extremely challenging
and if somebody has cracked the code on
it i would love to to hear more about it
but
you are making investments but you're
making investments in marketing
particularly in brand but also in in
doing growth marketing demand generation
based on belief uh and you're looking
for measurement and you're able to do
measurement for things that you can
measure but for large parts of your
investment that you're not able to
measure you're really you're really
really investing based on the thesis uh
that brand matters and it does matter
but there is no credible way of proving
it how much it matters and how much you
should invest in it and that i think is
the biggest challenge and the biggest
difference also between b2b and b2c
the way
business gets done is very different
brand is still important for both of
them but how much companies invest in it
and how much companies invest generally
in marketing as a percentage of revenue
i think varies greatly between b2b and
b2c
because of how consumers buy ultimately
and what drives those decisions
i can look at a youtube video and i can
make a decision uh in my personal life
in the next 30 minutes or in the next
day i certainly am not going to make
that decision at work when i might be
investing you know hundreds of millions
of dollars on my company's behalf uh
those decisions tend to be complex they
tend to have many decision makers and
you need to cover a much broader
spectrum of those decision makers and
and create um positive impressions and
create intent with them and as jesse was
saying at the right time you might have
four years three years two years in
between then there is no purchase intent
that exists there is no decision that
has to be made
totally i think everything you just
unpacked could literally be its own
episode
alone um so i'll go to one last question
for you um we obviously had tai from
linkedin on earlier i see you know
you're active on linkedin uh using it as
a platform um for you as a brand um
where um where do you see sort of the
role of sort of executive presences on
social um playing a role again um
connecting with customers in the spirit
of um your long lead cycles the
important of relationship and how a lot
again in during covid we found ways
digitally to scale that how do you think
about you know either linkedin
specifically or you know your brand or
executive brands across the organization
playing a role in your future strategy
yeah i'm a big believer people don't
like to hear from corporations they like
to hear from other people
and when you have
executives who can communicate well and
who can have a personality uh when they
are on linkedin uh that conversation is
a lot more natural and a lot more human
uh than a company that you know is a
corporate uh feed trying to push out no
matter how interesting those tweets are
once in a while they'll have a viral
moment they'll have a breakthrough
moment which is great but most of the
times uh the most attention that we pay
to are what other people have to say and
if you look at every successful company
that's out there you will see that
they're led by
executives or a group of executives that
are able to leverage the power of
platforms like linkedin much better
because they have a presence that's not
just talking about the company and what
they do but it's talking about what
they're experiencing in their personal
lives what they're seeing in the
professional lives and combine the
message which is much more credible and
much more human than a company just
putting it out from its handle couldn't
agree more totally agree awesome thanks
so much for joining us i appreciate it
thank you
that was fantastic thank you siddharth
and thank you caitlyn
great to have you
all right let's welcome peter chun to
the stage
hey peter oh look at you
bill caitlin
i've really enjoyed everything thus far
it's such a good thing it's been a good
one it's been a good one i love that
you've got i think i see some empathy
bottles behind you the b and the b to b
stands for bottles
there we go
b to b b to bottles okay let's go so
peter is vaynermedia's global head of
partnerships and we're very excited to
have his first guest up
miss jennifer chase who is the global
cmo and evp at sas how are you jennifer
hey andrea hey peter nice to see you hey
jen
oh my goodness we are so excited about
this conversation we did want to share
that in addition to running a
data-driven marketing strategy that
helps in building i love these the
global brand awareness demand gen and
customer experience for sas i have a
feeling you're also packing your son up
to go to college tomorrow we heard a
little fun fact yeah that's right off to
boston university tomorrow so i'm gonna
need some of those bottles in peter's
background send the address we're
sending them all over but only
one
very fired up you guys take it away
awesome thanks andrea hi jen how are you
great to see you in this environment wow
it's good to be here what a great
episode oh
so good yeah i think there's a couple of
of themes that we've had thus far that
we want to definitely introduce into
this conversation uh before we get into
it um for those that don't know sas is a
50-year business can you just do a quick
primer for the audience yeah
there's so much coming down the pipe for
you folks uh and i think it'll just help
set context for the combo sure and um
and we're sas so when you think of sas
it's it's think sassy so your intro
reminds me how much work i still have
left to do
brand awareness um but yes we're sas we
are we're um we're a 45 year old company
we um you know we invented the category
of analytics and so we think of
ourselves as the founder and future of
analytics the future of analytics is in
ai um so that's that's who we are we're
very much known for um we pioneered a
lot of workplace culture uh um that that
you see very standard in today's um
today's marketplace but yeah analytics
and ai when you think sas
sas software think analytics ai
and you know as i've gotten to know you
over previous events one of the things
that
really stood out to me is you've been
there for
over two decades and one of the things
i've always admired about you is how
fresh
and current and innovative your your
thinking is how do you stay fresh in an
environment where you've been for as
long as you have in a company that's
been as legacy oriented as it is
yeah and and um it dates me but i've
been here over two decades what that's
offered me is a chance to really see the
business from a lot of different angles
i've had four or five different careers
while i've been here i've seen how we
how we make software i see how we
deliver software i see how we market
software so um i've got a better
understanding of our business our value
chain and i understand our customers and
how they've evolved over the 45 years um
how do i stay current um it well jesus
sessions like this it's
constantly inspired our our space in in
technology and what we do is evolving so
fast so if you're not staying up to to
to speed on the technology and
technology space you're going to get
left behind and so i've always made it a
point to stay very externally focused so
that i can drive the internal
initiatives that i need to
and look some of the the the really
exciting stuff that you folks have
coming up as a business is for those
that may not know you you you are kind
of setting the groundwork for an ipo uh
shortly uh no no timeline to be
communicated other than it's in the
works and
if a 50-year business is looking to move
an ipo in its current state um you're
looking at and sas arguably has been too
humble to a fault
and when you think of most of the
business decision makers and b2b buyers
today being millennials how do you think
about building brand as you think about
sas tomorrow
right and you think about retail
institutional investors but more
importantly the customer base is likely
going to evolve as well so how do you
think about that challenge
yeah you know i'll harken back to what
um jim said earlier the economic um
drivers of the future are going to be
b2b business and he talked about um ryan
roslansky's presentation and the the top
ipos in the future the biggest ipos in
the future being b2b um you know we've
set a high ambition for ourselves
internally we want that to be us
and so that means we have to look at how
we market differently now there's some
things that stay the same
in my 10 years since i've taken over as
a cmo i've definitely made a case for
the importance of brand building and
that was definitely something that was
probably perceived more as arts and
crafts in in the past right i i think it
made me we've thought of it as a little
bit more frivolous and um i've made the
case for that and i've i've really
tried to work with my team to
demonstrate the value i love jim's
comment on brand marketing drives
results so so brand awareness that's an
enduring strategy that needs to evolve
though um you know we've got demand gen
efforts that really keep our eye on that
in your revenue um yeah as a company we
were practicing esg before esg became
something that was was sexy and required
even in in some cases so we've got a lot
of foundation to build from but we have
to do some things differently um it's
really important that we clarify our
promise and clarify our promise to mark
to the market in a way that is relevant
to our audience in a way that's really
useful
and i think we've got some improvement
to do there if i'm if i'm honest with
with myself and the work that we've done
um we do have new audiences to your
point we haven't catered to uh
an investor audience and so we have to
introduce ourselves um to that audience
and that'll be part of of the future for
me
and then internally the ipo is inspiring
us to act with more agility
more operational rigor internally and
i'm using this as an opportunity to
boost our creativity as well
well you know with with the changes that
need to be made uh you in the driver's
seat here uh one of the things i've also
always appreciated are some of your hot
takes absolutely um so let's let's get
into it there's a lot happening you know
post pre-pandemic during post
vw becoming more human than ever before
um dealing with a lot of incumbency a
lot of dollars big budgets
uh give us give us one or two hot takes
yeah
yeah sure i mean i'm fresh off con too
my first ever time uh attending that
event and yeah what a spectacle oh my
gosh that was just a load of inspiration
um
i i was so excited to see how um b2b was
celebrated at this event and i recognize
it wasn't like that in the past i mean
there definitely is this vibe that
there's a b2b renaissance going on right
now
and um so you know hats off to to
to you to um to linkedin to jim stangle
everybody who's making that that um
important right now
i uh i think i came back and shared with
with my um with my peers and with my
marketing team that the the bar was just
raised on creativity
hands down so whatever we were doing
yesterday as good as it was it the
future is going to be far more creative
uh and and i think again back to not
creative in an arts and crafts way this
is going to be creative in a way that
drives business growth and we have to we
have to level up our game so that was my
message um loud and clear and i think
that's exciting to me for for b2b
marketers um you know i i think how we
talk has to i think as b2b marketers
we've often almost disjointed a human
that's that's making a decision in a
buying group and a buy at work in a
buying decision from the human that goes
home and is with their family and enjoys
tv and enjoys um you yeah whatever it is
they might do so i think we have to do a
better job as b2b marketers in
understanding our consumer and their
entirety and recognizing that while
there's differences and nuances with
them as a b2b buyer they're still humans
and so let's relate to them as the
humans that they are in a really
relevant and meaningful way
yeah and and the r word that you
discussed relevance is um is a really
tricky conversation i think we see with
a lot of companies we speak with because
there's this assumption of what
corporations and brands want their brand
to be
versus a deep understanding of what
humans care about and so i think now
more than ever we're seeing this uh you
know discussed earlier in some of the
conversations is this idea of relevance
versus reach what do you think are some
of the biggest challenges you'll have to
overcome
as you think about brand voice content
going ipo external optics of what the
brand wants it to be seen as versus kind
of the pivot towards thinking about hey
the contemporary consumer is more human
and more relevant oriented than ever
before yeah
and i you know what the way i see it and
what what we need to do better at sas
is um recognizing that that buyer um
that customer that prospect um when do
they need logical information and when
do they need an emotional connection and
you know we've nailed the logical i like
all of us in b2b we've done our we've
done our white papers long-form white
papers we've done all of that type of
content appeals to the logical aspect of
the buying decision we have to get to
the other side of the coin and really
look at the emotional side and that's
where i think you can become relevant in
a way that that connects uh with your
with your buyer your prospect in a way
that you can't when you start talking
speeds and feeds uh so for us we leaned
in heavily on this notion of creativity
or on curiosity we believe curiosity is
is the heart of human progress and and
so that's going to inspire innovation so
our campaign has has leaned into
curiosity so that we could connect in
that more emotional way and then we'll
begin to talk about all right once you
know who we are and then we can connect
with you in an emotional way then we can
talk about capability and promise but
don't don't do that first yeah so build
trust build trust yeah yeah
um one more question because i think
we're we're coming up on the finish line
here
your outlook for the space in 2023 uh
kind of what disruption do you think set
to come our way in the b2b space what
are you most hopeful for yeah
you know
i think the disruption you can't talk
about disruption that we see coming
without talking about an economic
downturn and that that's all that that
we're hearing right now and how that
might affect um us as society as
business as an economy as as individuals
i think about it from a marketing
perspective if you haven't been doing
some of the things we've talked about in
the past if you haven't been doing you
know being useful and being authentic
and relevant to your consumer you're not
going to be top of mind to them if we do
go into a a situation like that
if you haven't been demonstrating the
the impact the commercial value of
marketing to your c-suite you're going
to see your budgets get cut right so i
think we need to be really mindful of
what happens and take lessons from the
past what happens in an economic
downturn and how can you best reach out
to your customers how can you make sure
you've got the resources to do that um
because you've been demonstrating the
value of marketing um that's a little
negative if i think about what i'm
hopeful for
if you do it with disruption and and
we've seen this very recently it does
tend to unite us and unite us in a way
that that brings us together to focus on
what's really important and i hope you
know as we look forward we're going to
see a world that's much more equitable
and sustainable and prosperous
well jen thanks again for inspiring us
for 10 minutes uh i can't wait to
continue the conversations with you and
all that you're going to do with this
ass brand and the upcoming ipo and best
of luck
thank you thanks peter
thanks to you both
all right peter last but certainly not
least we have emily ha who is the
corporate vp of business applications at
microsoft
uh she is responsible for the global go
to market strategy and driving business
growth for microsoft dynamics 365 and
the power platform
prior to joining microsoft emily was
with oracle and she also served as c cmo
for two high growth sas businesses we're
so excited to have you welcome emily
thank you so much for having me hi emily
thanks for taking time out of your day
and investing it with us and all those
tuning in
of course it's a pleasure
uh maybe we can start with i mean you've
you've been a very seasoned uh
cmo in the b2b space and uh microsoft is
obviously a a household name in every
capacity in every way
what's something you learned about
microsoft in kind of your first year and
a half there or so that you didn't know
about the business that others might not
as well
uh that's a fantastic question and by
the way you've had just like awesome
guests i've been so inspired by all the
conversations you've had
and um sas happened to be our partner of
the year so i'm so glad you have no i
did not know that that's awesome
yeah so it's a great transition to
microsoft um but in terms of uh what i
learned at microsoft i'm relatively new
so i've been here almost a year and one
of the reasons i came to microsoft is
like you said it's a brand it's a
household name um it has an awesome
brand and i know the company is very
invested in building brand love and
cultivating the sense of community and
that's has that has been true since i
joined the company the other reason i
joined the company is the cultural
transformation that satya has led and
i'm a big believer in culture which is
not something that every company focuses
on and microsoft they just really put
the cultural aspect at the front and
center and i would venture to say that
culture has driven the business growth
and microsoft and has really led the way
uh so that's something that has been
true as well since i joined the company
the one thing that i did not realize is
um
microsoft puts a lot of emphasis on
their business model
and how we financially and operationally
deliver the customer experience so
customer experience for them is not a
word we talk about in marketing but it's
deeply embedded in how we organize our
business model how we organize ourselves
financially and operationally so that's
been really refreshing to see
yeah let's let's keep going on that
because you know microsoft has
consistently been one of the most
innovative and most adaptive companies
that's out there
and your process to stay relevant has
always been at the core of delighting
your customers and that's that seemingly
is that sound uh you know the consistent
narrative how do you all do that how do
you how do you maintain that
relationship and trust and innovation um
keeping customer at the core
yeah it really stems from one of our
core values which is the world's mindset
and our ceo satya always says um you
know it's important to have a growth
mindset versus fixed mindset he calls it
be a
learn it all versus a know it all and
inside the company we define gross
mindset as a desire to learn and
therefore tendency to embrace challenges
persist in the face of setback see
failure as essential to mastery and
learn from criticism and find lessons
and inspiration in the success of others
and in marketing
we take this to heart
we are the guardian of our business
model and we practice our growth mindset
in order to understand our customers
needs how they're evolving and how we
can deliver
our operational processes to delight our
customers and we practice something
called business model bravery which is
the one i love and this
model bravery is a it represents
continuous innovation and optimization
of the entire business operations
experience and there are three key
components one is financially so the way
we capture value in other words the way
we make money the second one is
operationally so how do we deliver value
from an operational perspective and the
third thing is organizationally how do
we align our teams to deliver the kind
of impact we want um
with for the customers and when we
practice business
model bravery we can adapt faster we can
align our teams faster and we can
accelerate our business transformation
faster
i mean that sounds first of all i love
that it's called business model bravery
because it takes a lot of courage to
drive change and listen to customers
feedback and evolve
especially when you're a juggernaut as
big as you are
it's a fascinating concept how does that
apply
do you see applying and how is it
relevant to b2b marketing today
for b2b marketing at the end of the day
is about how we deliver value to our
customers
and um when we look at business model
it's really about watching how customers
are consuming our products and how they
derive value and organize the
operational and the
customer experience accordingly so a few
examples um when the company pivoted to
towards the cloud we watched our
customers consume differently in their
cloud experience so for azure work we
introduced a consumption based model and
we allow customers to pay as you go and
this is a dramatic change from the
user-based pricing model
and then in the gaming space for example
we have a game pass
for xbox and that's a subscription-based
model as well uh in some cases we
declared new tam so for example during
the pandemic we notice a lot of
customers are spending a lot more time
in microsoft teams getting
having fun with customers for each other
and they're spending a lot more time in
their productivity to do productivity
tools like office so um what the
customers were asking for is we are kind
of overwhelmed by the information and
tools we're using can you give us a
curated employee experience so we
introduced microsoft viva which is a
a
tool that brings together is the
employee experience platform that bring
together communication knowledge
learning resources and
insights in the flow of work and by
doing so we declared new tan by
introducing a new suite of applications
and now we're evolving a microsoft viva
to tailor to row specific uh employee
experience uh for example recently we
just introduced viva sales as something
that tailors to the sellers um and
another example is we kind of watch how
uh customers consume our
product portfolio microsoft the great
thing is we have a
very large product footprint so
we have business applications we have
personal computing and we also have
cloud infrastructure and by watching how
customers are consuming value we can
package these applications differently
to tailor to their needs and this is why
we introduce the industry clouds for
example that offer a industry specific
experience
yeah the technology is certainly uh
behind almost all of the change that's
happening in the industry how do you see
the technology
playing a role with this kind of
business model bravery to help you know
permeate and push a lot of the change
that's happening or in your organization
especially an organization that's as big
as it is
yeah i mean technology is
a microsoft business but it's also the
way
a vehicle for us to deliver the customer
experience so technology impacts
business model bravery because the
essence of our products is technology
and for us is is really about sometimes
we have to deviate from taking a
technology-centric point of view but
more a customer-centric point of view
and use technology as a vehicle to
deliver customer value but additionally
we
um
the the way we engage customers is no
longer just in person we need customers
through the digital experience so we
have to think through the customer
journey from a digital point of view and
we always aspire to streamline simplify
the customer experience in order to
delight customers and and deliver more
value
amazing um and just to close us out
emily as you think about next year
and some of the changes that have
happened in the space
what are you most looking forward to in
2023 as we think about b2b and building
brands and businesses
yeah in this sense i really concur i
love what jennifer said um in her
response i think when i look back in the
last couple of years the pandemic has
been uniting for us although it's been a
negative experience but i think as a
humanity we kind of came together and
we found a lot of common ground now
as we head into next year there's this
sense of
uh maybe the recession is happening how
can we use technology to
allow customers to do uh more with less
and that's the central theme we're
hearing from our customers and my hope
is with technology we can
use technology as a
unifying force for humanity and bring us
together and i also hope customers can
use technology to do more with less and
weather through the store
amazing
uh thank you again for joining us today
emily really enjoy the conversation
um and very fortunate for listeners
they're able to sit through it thank you
thank you so much for having me thank
you emily and thank you peter that was
fantastic thank you andrew woohoo
so and thank you to curvang who says
that
the lineup was pretty good he said
lineup is pretty good we
we tend to agree on this one as well
more and more more on b2b thanks
everybody for joining us please come
back september 29th we're going to have
an episode that's all about tv 3.0 we're
going to bring together top marketers to
discuss what tv 3.0 looks like
especially with the rise of cord cutters
and cord nevers we'll discuss the
evolution of tv
and how you can strike up a plan that
positions you for what's next uh please
continue to keep the conversation going
marketing or marketing for the now and
also register for upcoming show at mftn
that's right mftn for marketing for the
now vaynerx.com we'll see you soon
thanks for joining